yeah there was some confusion from the
secretary of state's office about when
additional election results would be
reported but we now know
no additional numbers will be reported
tonight
it will now be tomorrow now the deputy
secretary of state for elections
explained his team knows the public
wants more results but
he has been saying before the election
they would not be final
on election night all active registered
voters in nevada were sent mail-in
ballots for the first time ever due to
the covet 19 pandemic in case they
didn't want to vote in person
ballots may still be in the mail some
signatures need to be confirmed by
voters if they were rejected
and there was a record number of mail-in
ballots already received
now president trump has said nevada
would steal the election
and he's criticized the system here
here's what thorley says
any evidence of voter fraud in nevada so
far
no no evidence whatsoever
of coordinated
widespread voter fraud
we have received a handful of complaints
with some allegations
again they're just allegations at this
point unproven
that we're looking into but no no
evidence of
voter fraud i asked for a specific
number being investigated
thorley said less than 10 and that law
enforcement
is involved in those investigations and
as we've reported
30 polling locations in clark county
were ordered by a judge to stay open
an extra hour until 8 pm instead of
7 pm that's after the trump campaign and
the nevada republican party filed a
lawsuit to keep them open because some
locations
had technical difficulties and got a
late start now i
asked thorley how that could have
affected our election keeping them
open one hour later he wouldn't comment
on any lawsuits but he did say
it just meant the results came in an
hour later
reporting live vanessa murphy 8 news now